these ukrainians left mariopol with just
the few belongings they could pack in a
hurry
which wasn't much
what was weighing these people down was
the memories of what they've seen and
what they've left behind
they've left a city of half a million
people surrounded by forces from russia
and donetsk
people who are now their hosts
nick describes living under shelling for
10 days as he made his way out of the
city with his wife child and
mother-in-law
we got into our car under constant
shelling there was no corridor we had no
help we just drove
we went from one village to another
spent four days in a cellar then five
days in a shed with no water no gas no
electricity no internet
that journey from mariopol east to this
village would have taken just 45 minutes
in peacetime
we survived as best we could only now
that we are safe are we going to work
out what we are going to do next
so few people seem to have made it out
of mariopol because according to the don
yet separatists the azov battalion that
holds the city is not letting civilians
leave
azov is a far-right paramilitary
neo-nazi group now integrated into
ukraine's national guard
the group in return accuses the russians
of violating the humanitarian ceasefires
considering the size of mariopol just
really a handful of people have made it
here an indication that despite the
promise of a secure humanitarian
corridor many people are still too
scared to leave
bernard smith al jazeera nova azovska
region